j'avais envie de parler d'un d'un sujet
qui crispe qui crée des tensions j'avais
envie de parler d'un sujet qui est à
bout parce que justement
parce qu'on se connaît pas finalement
les communautés est-ce que vous avez eu
l'impression de jouer un rôle je n'ai
pas l'impression que c'est un rôle dans
le sens où j'ai pas eu à faire le
travail qu'on peut faire sur un
personnage quand on tourne un film qu'on
prépare où il faut rentrer dans ce qu'on
appelle la peau du personnage et tout
moi j'ai l'impression d'être d'être
cette personne mais que je me promène
dans des zones
scénarisé totalement inventé et des
zones vrais mais je vous dirai pas
lequel
[Musique]
la chambre des petits pourquoi toi tu es
quoi maintenant un grand pourquoi tu es
revenu c'est chaud j'arrive pas à le
dire tu es pas mal j'espère non je suis
pas malade
[Musique]
je l'aurais pas fait lire le Sénat donc
ils ont voulu ils ont rien lu il savait
rien et pour être tout à fait honnête si
je leur avais fait lire le scénario ils
auraient jamais fait le film parce
qu'ils auraient eu peur peur de regarder
les autres peur peut-être de la famille
peur d'une il y en a qui voit
c'est la prière de l'abandon
Charles de fou quoi ils se sont laissés
faire en fait ils ont aimé jouer ils ont
joué à jouer ils ont joué à faire les
acteurs ils ont joué
ma mère elle voulait pas qu'on la
maquille et se maquiller les mêmes elle
mon père il comprenait pas que tout le
matos dans dans le couloir
ils nous ont pas fait payer la le décor
et le résultat
il y a eu plusieurs étapes ils ont vu le
film la première fois ils ont eu un choc
de personnes qui se voit en grand en
grand écran donc ils étaient incapable
de rentrer dans le film ou dans
l'histoire et la deuxième projection ils
sont rentrés dans le film
et la troisième projection ils l'ont vu
avec du public et là ils étaient très
apaisé très rassuré parce que ça riait
les scènes comiques parce qu'il faut le
dire c'est une comédie aussi et puis il
y a des scènes comiques il faut jouer
avec et rire avec la religion et la foi
et les croyances et les coutumes il y a
pas de problème on peut vraiment rire
avec ça c'était difficile de filmer
cette quête retranscrire une sorte de
transcendance ou la foi ou ce n'est pas
évident non pas évident du tout mais
c'est pas évident d'abord et avant tout
parce que justement c'est compliqué de
parler de religion j'avais envie de
parler d'un d'un sujet qui crispe qui
crée des tensions j'avais envie de
parler d'un sujet qui est à bout parce
que justement
parce qu'on se connaît pas finalement
les communautés par exemple ce qu'on
entend comme concept le vivre ensemble
c'est bien c'est un beau projet mais le
vivre ensemble c'est avant tout se
connaître donc se connaître c'est quoi
c'est
communiquer communiquer c'est aller dans
les lieux de culte les uns des autres
peut-être et c'est parler de nous et le
mot communauté il est pas forcément à
chaque fois péjoratif puisque à chaque
fois quand on ta communauté on pense aux
communautarisme mais il y a des
communautés il faut être honnête il faut
dire ce qu'il en est des communautés
avec des appartenances et des
confessions tellement différentes avec
des rites et des liturgies et
j'ai envie d'envisé envisager ça comme
une richesse en France alors certes il y
a la laïcité c'est indispensable mais ça
doit pas écarter gommer la spiritualité
ou la tentative de spiritualité ou la
trait vers la spiritualité ça fait
combien de temps que le
catholicisme vous attire
j'ai l'impression que
[Musique]
que ce déclencheur avec l'image et
l'idée de la Vierge Marie puisque c'est
l'idée c'est une idée à la base quand
tes gamins la représentation c'est nella
donc j'avais 5-6 ans et puis après elle
se invite elle s'invite dans ma vie elle
s'invite dans le film c'est elle la star
du film en fait en vrai la vraie star du
film c'est elle
dans des places à ma mère
qu'est-ce qui vous a précisément séduit
c'est l'Église c'est la charité c'est
les textes il y a beaucoup de choses il
y a beaucoup de choses déjà c'est pas
juste être attiré par il y a aussi
c'est-à-dire qu'on ne peut pas parler de
là on va sans parler de là on vient
d'ailleurs c'est ce que les catholiques
font et disent en appelant les Juifs nos
frères aînés dans la foi moi je suis ému
de voir qu'on lit des extraits de la
Torah dans les messes de l'Ancien
Testament aussi ce que je lis ce que je
vois
là dans le monde catholique
ne reconnecte à mes études même du
Talmud il y a une préparation guillemets
avec avec les rationnels on est un peu
rodé en fait quand je découvre les
textes je me dis ah ben j'ai déjà été
confronté j'ai déjà côtoyé cette chose
qui est rationnelle la quête de Dieu
l'idée de Dieu l'hypothèse de Dieu donc
c'est pas complètement
nouveau pour moi puisqu'on est toujours
dans la même quête alors les textes sont
différents alors mais ça a été
peut-être le beau le culte du beau d'une
beauté en tout cas vous dites être
touché par la joie des catholiques ou la
voyez-vous c'est pas spontanément ce
qu'on pense les églises moi j'entends ça
de l'autre moi je j'entends ça de
l'autre côté par exemple très souvent
mes amis cathos me disent emmène-moi un
mariage juif t'es tellement joyeux c'est
tellement beau c'est tellement kiffant
vous dansez vous chantez mais oui c'est
vrai justement allons mariage des hommes
des hommes
mais cette joie dont je parle c'est
c'est d'ailleurs c'est un mot dans mon
spectacle que je caricature un peu parce
que il peut être aussi un peu
caricatural quand certains cathos
parlent de joie c'est une grande joie
c'est une joie je me réjouis parfois il
y a un excès comme ça qui me fait un peu
rire et je veux me moquer avec tendresse
aussi de ça mais la joie non je parle je
crois que c'est
aussi
ce dont vous avez parlé d'amour
universel formulé assumer par exemple
une forme de fraternité en humanité moi
j'aime bien cette idée là parce que
souvent entre les communautés on est
obligé de passer par un truc
œcuménique vivre ensemble on n'est pas
les mêmes mettons-nous mais on oublie
qu'il y a une humanité donc l'idée de la
fraternité en humanitaire me plaît déjà
vous leur envoyez quelque chose au
catholique
je m'inspire je partage je regarde mais
non c'est pour moi c'est un prolongement
c'est une connexion ah non je suis
jaloux de Noël
c'est pas c'est pas le sujet c'est pas
le sujet du film pour moi on joue pas à
baptême pas baptême
d'ailleurs le baptême
[Musique]
c'est la responsabilité c'est une c'est
un point de départ c'est même les
cadeaux eux-mêmes mes amis qui disent ça
y est j'ai baptisé c'est bon c'est réglé
non c'est pas réglé ta vie c'est un
point de départ c'est toute ta vie que
tu vas tu vas étudier tu vas essayer
d'être un meilleur tu vas essayer de
comprendre l'eau tu vas essayer d'être
sur le chemin
[Musique]
non je suis pas là dedans je pense à
truc qu'est-ce que j'ai envie qu'est-ce
que je peux prendre là et que j'ai pas
là et que non non c'est c'est une
curiosité c'est une ouverture au
dialogue c'est une ouverture à aux deux
communautés qui se parlent je crois que
le film il est il est pas sur la
religion du tout même il est sur la foi
au sens large est-ce que j'ai la foi
aujourd'hui en la vie en moi est-ce que
je crois en qu'est-ce que je pense de ma
vie aujourd'hui en tant qu'homme où j'en
suis si cette tête là qui m'intéresse
pas est-ce que tu préfères aller à la
messe ou à la synagogue
tu changes de Dieu change tes parents
fais-toi adopter on n'a pas envie de te
perdre
[Musique]
pour toi vous vivez ensemble mais elle
te fous la paix c'est pas toi que je
vais expliquer ce que c'est que de
perdre un fils pourquoi tu nous fais pas
une crise à cinquantaine comme tous ces
mecs là tu t'achètes une voiture de
sport très basse tu te tapes une petite
nana très haute et tu arrêtes de nous
emmerder la maison juive tu peux
chercher la sortie personne n'a jamais
trouvé ça va je suis en train de répéter
un truc je me prépare en fait
[Musique]
il faut me sortir c'est une compétition
d'apnée
[Musique]